here we go again it's another try not to
laugh I'm not gonna lie to you guys I
would never lie to you guys I only tell
you truths
these videos are not funny there is
nothing to laugh at there's no such
thing as funny in the world it all is a
farce a lie it doesn't exist and
therefore there should be no reason for
any of us to laugh make sense okay let's
do this not funny
[Music]
don't think that's funny at all
is harassment
[Music]
as a hero I wish I was I wish I was half
as cool as that guy was I wish I feel
like that one was a direct attack at me
and I feel very offended what that is so
disrespectful and therefore not funny
I don't like this I don't like this
[Music]
what happened don't you remember me
don't you baby never seen you in my life
believe me I would remember can't you
remember my face is there something in
my teeth
not funny has you really been far even
as decided to use even go want to look
more like call 9 8 5 6 5 5 2500 inside
the details for go further and even more
decided to use you can really be far as
decided twice as much to use and go wish
for it when you decide far even once to
use and go want then get really far even
has decided to use and look more like
and go after it's just common sense
apply today do I have a straight
[Music]
well I can't say you didn't deserve that
okay here's the first face where she
realizes she came very close to pain
and/or death this is the face of a
little [ __ ] who realized that they
didn't die and therefore are now
invulnerable
this is [ __ ] level 2 where the [ __ ] Lord
in question has discovered that they are
indeed not involved
hmm yeah especially their Brundle yeah
[Music]
that's real cute
water completely innocent video of a
giraffe and a fence post you bloody
bastard
Barry [ __ ] you bloody [ __ ] letter
bloody [ __ ] [ __ ]
Vicky like [ __ ] you you [ __ ] bloody
bastard you suffer pain true bloody
vengeance you do blunder but divine
blood we know right bloody [ __ ] you [ __ ]
me I [ __ ] you bloody body boss for you
running like that one you wanna [ __ ]
for linear but hurting yourself that is
beautiful they came to a reconciliation
they got all their anger out and it no
no ma put the dogs away to something in
the backyard my put the dogs away
there's something in the backyard
ah ah what he's back
Oh bar full of cops that cat is back
yeah the one that looks like it's
wearing makeup I love sequels you're on
camera say something is night and night
before that was three women walking down
the street dead weight I thought as a
hey you three women why are y'all
walking down the street that way like
nothing down there and they flew away I
saw them with some birds not there's a
good story I think you just [ __ ] thing
I've ever seen
ah a so sad I wasn't laughs of [ __ ]
movements of my diaphragm there ah there
that there there cause there goes my
chance hair goes poof gone my only
chance that we don't need to look at
boobs
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna do it was gonna happen I knew
what was gonna happen
I knew [ __ ] well that's it for now thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see more funny videos that
I've laughed to and also not laughs to
put a link in the description below or
go to the try not to laugh playlist
there's a bunch of them subscribe for
more cool videos ring that Bell
comment like add to favorites favorites
even the thing anymore
I don't know shout it from your rooftop
write it in the sand put a link right
out the URL to this video put it in a
bottle cork it toss it in the ocean then
have a good day thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye